most of the writing for Goodwill Hunting
was done improv style it took us forever
to write that screenplay I think we
wrote thousands and thousands of pages
it was at a time when they were like
these filmmakers you know Spike Lee they
do the right thing and Richard Lincoln
did slacker and Quentin did Reservoir
Dogs and the way you did that was to do
it inexpensively and so we deliberately
wrote a movie that was mostly people
talking in rooms and we knew nothing
about like structure or any we were just
like writing scenes and jamming them
together and would tape record and then
re-go over the tape and pick out the
good parts I think we were young enough
to be just sort of an inexperienced
enough to just sort of think maybe it'll
work we were shocked that it even got
released and mostly it was done because
we had nothing else to do you know so it
was a really inefficient way to write
and I think we avoided writing together
all these years because each of us were
like Well we'd never have time to do
that and yet we found this time around
yeah the first movie we've written in 25
years or something when we actually did
an outline for what we were going to
write and we actually wrote really fast
and I think that was just a product of
having made movies for 30 years we kind
of finally picked up on the structure